come on dude what was that what was that
it's a bird call man I'm trying to get
good at this stuff okay sounds like a
guy screaming it feels like you should
just be able to blow into it like it
doesn't seem like a complicated stop it
man what is happening you so bad at I
don't know man it's frustrating to
me it worked
oh my God holy that is a full ass
Hawk oh my God okay sort of glaring at
us yeah you see that maybe we head out
yeah maybe we head it bye little girlly
see you can't believe that we saw Hawk I
know manol
yeah is it following us feels like it
is what's going on
here I think it's just walking it's all
good I think it looks like it's hunting
us well why don't we just pick it up a
little yes
sir go go to the Rock go
Traverse it Traverse The Rock stop stop
it
stop does it not know it can fly e dude
yuck what a little weirdo why
did it walk away with an attitude
man Jesus that was scary very SC
hell